have you ever had a dream neo
that you were so sure was real
what if you were unable to wake from
that dream how would you know the
difference between the dream world and
the real
your seatbelt dorothy because kansas is
going bye-bye
[Music]
while we were making the first matrix i
felt like that it's something beyond
yourself it's big
the experience of making the movies was
such a transformative time in my life
it was such an opportunity of a lifetime
i remember leaving the movie theater
knowing that things were just going to
be different in my life
you can't quantify how much it changed
the world
walked out of theater and lost myself
finally somebody gets me
i watched it went out bought another
ticket and watch it again blew my mind
blew everybody else's mind so what do
you need besides a miracle guns
lots of guns
these massive sequences with cars
flipping
[Music]
and explosions everywhere
bullet time
[Music]
slow motion man that's the most iconic
thing that i remember neo dodging the
bullets i never thought dodge this was
going to be a big deal dodge this
i was like oh my god this is amazing
the ambition of it's thought
try to realize the truth
there is no spoon
i'm amazed at their point of view about
reality and about the human brain it
altered people's thoughts what is real
what is reality even in my own life just
looking around and being like oh my god
we're in the matrix i would literally
think that
mr anderson it's sort of impossible to
articulate how it's seeped into our
minds and culture i can't even remember
not having seen it i can't remember my
life before the world of the matrix
what do you know you can't explain
but you feel it
matrix
do you want to know what it is
the matrix as an idea has lasted 20
years people use terminology like are
you going to take the red pill
you're either going to take that blue
pill you're going to take the red
everything entered pop culture and
stayed we say a glitch in the matrix the
fact that that's a part of the lexicon
deja vu a deja vu is usually a glitch in
the matrix it happens when they change
something
i think this is one of the few movies
that has really has seeped its way into
every kind of facet of popular culture
i'll run into young people who've done
college courses all of the philosophies
and ideas around the matrix
[Music]
it's this amazing magical mythological
world that has been created using
numbers and digits
but it's actually about consciousness
it's actually about thought
billions of people just living out their
lives
oblivious
you'll hear the sentences the matrix
changed my life
sorry to say thank you change mine too
[Music]
[Music]
you